- Let's get to our first guest,
even in the crazy year of 2020,
she's been as busy as ever.
You can catch her in
Space Force on Netflix
and in her Emmy winning role on
The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel on Amazon.
Plus, this summer,
she's back with the new season
of Hollywood Game Night.
I love Hollywood Game Night.
Take a look.
- Everybody focus, and
here is our first dance.
Go!
(audience laughter)
- Vogueing.
- That's right, Vogue.
- What were you doing?
What is happening to me?
- [Player] Breakdancing!
- Limbo!
- [Jane] That is right.
(audience cheers)
- Twerking.
- [Jane] Twerking.
- Miss Jane Lynch,
Hello, can you hear me?
- There's Kelly Clarkson.
- Oh, hi Jane.
Hi!
How are you?
- I'm well, how are you?
- I'm well, I think we're,
you know, all, you know,
every day is like, okay.
That's what I feel like every day is.
- Absolutely.
- Hey, you know how much I
love Hollywood Game Night,
probably more than I should,
cause I'm annoying when I play games.
But is anyone there?
This is a real question.
- Yes.
- Is anyone as competitive
as me this season?
- Yes.
But there's a difference
between the two of you.
And I will tell you what that is.
Yvette Nicole Brown is
extremely competitive,
but unlike you, Kelly,
she's stealthy.
- Oh.
She's sneaky about it.
You are obvious.
That's the word.
You're obvious and you're transparent
and delightful and charming.
Whereas she just kind
of sits back and goes,
pew,
like a Scorpio, you know,
she comes like out of
the depth of the ocean
and goes and bites you.
- Yeah.
And you're like, what just happened?
- Exactly.
- I wish I were more like a ninja,
but I'm still obvious.
- You gotta be Kelly.
- I love, I love the game night.
You did you did a special episode though,
from your house, looking
into other celebrities homes,
which I thought was kind of cool,
whose house made you most jealous?
- I loved my house the best.
- I love it!
- It's confirmed my design
choices in my partner
who's really good at this too,
but I mean everybody's house,
you couldn't see theirs as much as ours,
but we had these really great steps,
like kind of architecturally,
that I'd never saw before this way.
And I was so thrilled with how we,
how we had the books and the shelves
and you know,
we kind of styled it and
we kept it that way too.
Cause it was kind of a mess
with a bunch of family pictures
and we made some edits.
We got rid of some family members, sorry,
we just made a really beautiful display.
And we kept it that way.
- That's awesome.
I love that answer too,
because I feel like we always
want what we don't have
and that's nice.
It's such a lovely thing to like, go,
"No, I like my home."
- I like yours too.
I don't know where you
are, but it looks great.
And it's beautiful.
- This is not--
I mean we're in my home,
but this is literally a set that,
they came,
like it was only allowed
like one person with a mask.
Like, I mean, this is literally,
it's an actual set in my living room
so my house doesn't normally
have my initials everywhere.
- I was gonna say.
- Not much of a tool, Jane.
- I got a big JL over there.
You just don't see it.
- That's awesome.
So Jane, we have the pandemic,
we have the black lives matter movement.
There's just a lot of change.
And I, you know,
I think that if we do it right,
it's a change in a great direction.
And I feel like it's been needing
to happen for generations.
But I was just curious how you
were processing everything.
- Well, you know,
there's this thing called Twitter
and it's a double edged sword.
- Amen.
- I've never laughed harder
than when I go through my Twitter feed.
I've never felt as heartbroken
I've never been as angry,
and that's the worst part.
So it's kind of a, that's
where I get my news.
It's been a bit of an addiction for me
and I'm suffering a little bit over it.
So I'm not sure where to put it,
you know,
there is just so much going on
and I feel like I got to know
what it is and I've got to
understand it, you know?
And I think that that's a healthy thing
because we are at a tipping point.
This is,
this is a really tender
moment in our history
and our
nation's history, you know,
are we going to survive this?
You know,
the institutions and,
are we going to tear each other apart?
I mean,
we're really, we're
really at a tipping point.
- [Kelly] I agree.
I agree.
Speaking of social change,
The Marvelous Mrs. Maisel
deals with a lot of
social change on the show.
How do you think the period of
that show reminds you of now?
- Well, it's in the early sixties,
so we wouldn't have the 68, 69 stuff,
the horrible assassinations
for a few years,
but it is very white dominated.
It is very male dominated
and, kind of like today,
and the women, like women today,
are trying to make their mark in comedy
and Midge Maisel is one of those pioneers
because she doesn't,
she doesn't agree with
the power structure.
She doesn't even, you know,
she reminds me of a way of,
in a way of Tina Fey and Amy Poehler,
who kind of just took a seat at the table
without being invited,
just they're entitled to it.
And I think that's who Midge Maisel is
and my character, Sophie Lennon,
is more of the old school.
You know,
you have to act in a certain way,
you have to make fun of your looks,
you have to say you're fat,
everything has to revolve around,
the comedy has to revolve
around how you can't get a date
or you can't get a
husband to stay with you
and, you know, Midge
is stepping up, going,
"That's not funny,"
you know?
And I say to her,
"Well, what's your gimmick?"
She says,
"I don't have a gimmick."
"I just, you know, I tell funny stories."
So, you know, very much like today.
- Yeah.
I mean, it's super sad in one aspect,
but also, like, super telling.